et fabien kovac nous a rejoint bonsoir
vous êtes avocat spécialiste en droit du
travail
on vient de le voir dans le reportage m
il ya des inquiétudes il y aura
forcément des salariés mis au chômage
technique
de quelle manière ce pompier lui pris en
charge par l'état oui bonsoir
effectivement on est dans une période où
il va falloir que salariés et
entreprises se serre les coudes se
serrent les mains et on fait tous cause
commune donc il ya plusieurs solutions
la première solution c'est l'entreprise
malheureusement on n'a plus de travail à
donner à ses salariés dans ces cas là on
peut effectivement faire du chômage
partiel à faire que le salarié va être
chez lui va être payé à hauteur de 70%
de son salaire et l'entreprise va
pouvoir avoir une aide de l'état qui va
prendre en charge ce salaire et puis
l'autre solution c'est si on peut avoir
une activité mais exercé chez soi on
peut à ce moment-là passé en télétravail
oui le télétravail c'est l'une des
options qui est fortement recommandée ça
soulève quand même plusieurs questions à
ce que les salariés premièrement peuvent
s'y opposer le salarié qui fait la
demande de télétravail
l'employeur ne peut en principe à s'y
opposer sauf motif légitime
un chaudronnier par exemple ne pourra
pas travailler chez lui en revanche si
c'est l'employeur qui fait la demande le
salarié peut en principe refusé d'où
l'intérêt d'une cohésion aujourd'hui
entre salariés et employeurs
est ce qu'il ya une démarche officielle
il ya quelque chose à faire au préalable
avant de se lancer dans du télétravail
non absolument pas il faut simplement
que l'employeur et le salarié tombe
d'accord sur les modalités d'exercice de
ce télétravail faut pas oublier que qui
dit télétravail dit pas je reste chez
moi et je suis libre de vaquer à mes
occupations je dois respecter mon
horaire de travail je dois pouvoir
répondre à mon employeur aux heures où
je suis censé travailler et cet
employeur il peut refuser le télétravail
où il doit forcément acceptée c'est une
obligation pour l'employeur d'accepter
le principe du télétravail sauf cas
particuliers comme je l'indiqué c'est
notamment le cas où le salarié ne peut
pas exécuter sa mission chez lui quand
on est derrière un ordinateur qu'on soit
derrière l'ordinateur sur son lieu de
travail dans l'entreprise ou chez soi
c'est la même chose par contre il ya
beaucoup de métiers manuels vous ça va
être beaucoup plus compliqué alors dans
ces cas là pas d'autre alternative c'est
seulement le chômage partiel qui est
recommandée il ya d'autres alternatives
chômage partiel mais là ça veut dire que
le salarié ne percevra que 70% de son
salaire
l'autre alternative c'est les congés
payés il ya beaucoup de salariés qui ont
des congés payés à prendre et qui ne les
ont pas pris salariés et employeurs
peuvent convenir de les prendre
maintenant
et dans ces cas-là ça veut dire que le
salarié va percevoir 100 % de son
salaire
merci fabien kovac d'avoir eu le temps
de répondre à nos questions je rappelle
que vous êtes avocat en droit du travail